So we're talking now about
mortgages and how to value them.
And if you remember a mortgage,
so the first mortgages, by the way, uh,
that we know have come from Babylonian
Times. It's not like, you know,
some American invented
the mortgage or something.
This was a 3,500,
3000,
800 years old. And we have on these
cuneiform tablets, these mortgages.
And so the idea of a mortgage
is you make a promise,
you back your promise with collaterals.
So if you don't keep the promise,
they can take your house and there's
some way of getting out of the promise
because everybody knows that you
might, the collateral, you know,
you might want to leave the home and
then you have to have some way of
dissolving the promise because the
promise involves many payments over time.
So it's making a promise,
backing it with collateral and finding
a way to dissolve the promise that exp
prearranged terms in case you
want to end it by prepaying.
And that prepaying is called
the refinancing option.
And because there's a refinancing option,
it makes the mortgage a
much more complicated thing.
And a much more interesting thing
and something that, for example,
a hedge fund could man could imagine
that it could make money trading.
So I just want to give you a slight
indication of how that could happen.
So as we said, if you have a
typical mortgage, you know,
say the mortgage rate is 8% maybe there's
a different answer than I do. Uh, okay.
So here we have an 8% mortgage with
a 6% interest rate to begin with.
Okay?
Now if it's an 8% mortgage,
the guy's going to have to pay much
more than 8% a year because a mortgage,
remember their level payments,
we're talking about fixed rate mortgages,
you pay the same amount every
single year for 30 years.
Now you're really paying monthly.
And I've ignored the monthly business
cause it's just too many months. Uh,
and there's 360 of them. So I'm
thinking of it as an annual payment.
You have to pay, of course more than
$8 a year, because if you're paying a,
if the mortgage rate were 8% and you had
a balloon payment on the ad and you pay
eight eight 108, that's the way they
used to work. But they were changed,
you know, so you could imagine the old
fashioned mortgage would pay eight eight,
eight,
eight 108 if you didn't pay your eight
somewhere along the line they confiscate
your whole house. Um, and then
take what was owed out of it.
And you could get out of it by paying
100 the new mortgages instead of paying
eight every year for 30 years,
you pay 8.8 every year for 30 years.
Because if you discount payments
of 8.8 forever, for 30 years,
at 8% you get a hundred.
So the present value is a hundred at
the agreed upon discounting rate or
mortgage rate, 8%. And so the,
you see how important this a discount
rate is and the remaining balance however,
is more it goes down because
every time you're paying,
you're paying more than the 8% interest
you're paying in the first year,
8.8 instead of eight.
And so that gap of 0.8 0.88 is used to
reduce the balance from a hundred to
99.117 and as you see,
the balance is going down over time
and making the lender's safer and safer
because the same houses backing it,
so it's called an amortizing mortgage.
Now why is it difficult to value?
Because you have the option
anytime you want and it's,
there's a good reason for that option.
Anytime you want,
you have the option of getting out of
the mortgage and just saying, okay,
I've paid three payments of 8.88
I don't want to do it anymore.
I want to pay off 97.13 and
then let's call it quits.
And they say, okay, and there's
nothing they can do about it. Now,
when are you going to
exercise that option?
You're going to exercise that option
either because you have to move.
That's the intention of it.
Or you'll exercise at one.
It's most advantageous to you.
Now,
why could it become advantageous
to exercise it? Well,
you don't really want
to exercise the option,
and this is the way most people think
of it backwards. They think, oh,
the interest rates are going down.
That means I'll get a new mortgage
with a lower interest rate.
They sh they're hoping for exactly the
wrong thing. If the interest rates go up,
what they've got is a much better,
uh,
mortgage because they're continuing to
buy at the same 8% interest and maybe,
uh,
interest rates and the economy.
If we come 12% and they're
actually making money.
So people who borrow in times
of high inflation do better.
When there's times of deflation,
the borrowers get crushed.
Irving Fisher said one of the main
reasons for the depression being so bad is
all the entrepreneurial people in
the account, in the country as usual.
We're borrowing. And then
there was a deflation, and
so they were getting crushed.
And the very people who drive the economy,
we're being hurt the most. And so he,
that feedback he said was responsible
for the severity part of the severity of
the depression. So you see
interest rates can go up or down.
And what happens when they go up,
they go up high enough to 19% you think,
my gosh,
I've made a fortune holding this mortgage.
I'm still borrowing at 7% 8% and um,
I'm uh,
you know,
I can invest my money at 19% so you're,
you've made a fortune and the poor
lenders gotten crushed. On the other hand,
if the interest rates go way down here,
so the present value of what you owe
if you kept paying, it becomes huge.
You don't have to face that big loss
because you just prepay at whatever the
remaining balance is there and then your,
you've protected your downside.
So by paying attention and deciding
when the optimal time to prepay is,
you can save yourself a lot of money and
thereby costs the bank a lot of money.
So when exactly should you prepay
when she's, you exercise your option?
Well in this example,
if you've never exercised it,
you'd be handing the bank effectively
$120 even though if I lent you 20 so the
bank would have made a 20% profit on you,
but if you exercise your ah,
your option optimally,
you're going to make not a hundred.
Uh, you're not going to make,
the bank is not going
to get $100 out of you.
They're going to even get
less than a hundred dollars.
They're going to get $98 out of you.
Okay.
So when exactly should you be
exercising your option? Well, I,
we went over this last time.
I'll do it once again.
So remember the payment you
old was 8.88 8.88 blah blah,
blah.
8.88.
The remaining balance started of course
at a hundred and then it went down to
99.11 and then it kept
going down from there.
Hey Saul, since I can't
remember the numbers, uh,
let's just call this B one the
remaining balance, which happened to be,
you know,
it was 99 point 11 the first time.
Let's call this B one and
then I went to B, two B,
three et Cetera,
and then be 30 it was equal to zero,
no remaining balance after that.
Okay, so we said, what should you do?
I'm going to do the calculation
now a little bit differently.
I said after every payment of 8.88
you could always say to yourself,
do I want to continue or
do I want to pay my option?
Now you notice that if I had divided
this by B one say if you had a mortgage
that was a little bit smaller,
barely over a dollar, for example,
um,
the payments would,
the payments would all that would divide
everything by B one the payments would
all be divided by B one.
Okay.
And the remaining balances
would all be divided by B one.
So I could always scale
this thing up or down.
There's nothing fancy about a hundred,
nothing important. About a hundred.
If the original coupon,
the original loan was for 200 you just
double all your payments and double all
your remaining balances.
What could be more obvious than that?
So I want to think in
those terms of a mortgage,
that star that always has a dollar left.
So suppose at any stage you had
a dollars left in your mortgage,
what would the, your remaining
balance was one, what would you,
so let's say at any node,
okay,
Nino, let's ask the
question. What is the value
of $1 of remaining balance?
Okay, so if you start at a hundred and
you haven't prepaid here, you've got B,
$2, of course, whatever
the value of that is,
you take divided by B two,
that's the value of $1.
So I'm just going to figure out the doll,
the value of $1 for balance
and want to call that.
Um, W let's say, I'll call that w. Okay.
If some node s so where am
I? I'm in some node. Um,
okay.
Uh, I'm in some node in this
interest rate tree, right?
Here's our interest rate tree and I'm
anywhere just here and I'm doing backward
induction.
So for all success or nodes,
I figured out what $1 remaining balances.
And let's say it's in period
one, two, three, four,
five. So I'm in period five. B Five. Okay.
So what is the remaining balance
at this? No, which I call ass.
So at some node right there
of, oh no, I've lost it. Uh,
so w s is going to be what?
It's going to be the minimum
of one.
You could just pay it if you wanted to
or you could wait one over one plus r s.
Okay. And then what would you
have to do? You would have to
make your payment. Well,
what's your payment?
The payment is this 8.88,
but divided by
B five.
Okay. Plus, um,
the remaining value
remaining balance of uh,
yeah,
of a dollar.
So B six
over be five times the remainder
times a w s up. Okay. Now why,
why is this right?
I hope it is right by the way.
Should have thought of
this a little before. Um,
okay.
Okay, well typically I,
so I've just taken the,
so this is the remainder of $1 left.
Okay.
So if I divide by B five here,
I'm not going to have a
remaining balance of the six.
I'm going to have a remaining
balance of B six Overby five.
So if I started with a dollar
of remaining balance, okay,
then I know that in the next period
I'm going to have B six or B,
$5 of remaining balance left.
Just didn't sound too
convincing by the way. Um,
okay. Well that's right. And that
happens with probability a half.
And then with the other probability a
half plus I make the payment but I go down
instead of up.
Okay.
And so I have B six over five.
Uh,
but I have w s down
and that's also times a half.
Okay.
So either I pay off my
rape remaining dollar or I,
uh, end up with this
many dollars, you know,
assuming I had a $1 remaining balance,
okay,
I'm either going to pay it
off the remaining balance
or I'm going to have this
much left next period and adult
remaining balances is going to be that.
Okay?
Okay.
So that's it.
So I know now by working this forwards,
I can always tell backwards.
I can tell what a dollar
at the beginning is worth.
And so it's exactly the same calculation
I did before except I'm talking about a
dollar.
I'm always figuring out a
dollar for meaning balance
instead of the whole thing.
Um, present value of
Kabul with the whole case.
So here's present value
of a dollar is principle.
And so remember the present value
of a callable mortgage was 98.8.
Here are the present value of a dollar.
Figure it out that way is 0.98.
Obviously it's divided by a hundred,
but the key is that now you can see just
by looking at it where the ones are is
where the guy decided to prepay. Okay.
So it's the same thing as before.
But you see before you couldn't tell
very easily from the numbers. Uh,
when I did the hundred,
sorry,
I'm going to make it before when I did
the present value with the hundred,
all these numbers were 98 to [inaudible]
97. So I mean, where is he prepaid?
It's hard to tell where the prepayment is.
If I do it all in terms of a
dollar of remaining balance,
then just by looking at the screen, I
can tell where the guy prepaid. Okay.
Because there ones there. So I know where
he's prepaid, wherever the ones are,
that means he's prepaid. So I can tell
very easily what he did. All right.
That's the only purpose of, of doing
this somewhat the same calculation,
this dilemma, trickier way. So
if you think about it a second,
you see I've just divided by,
I've always reduced things to what
if you had a dollar left? All right?
So this tells us what to do
when the guy should prepaid,
when he shouldn't prepay.
So if you're now in the world
looking at what's happening,
you can find the historical
record of how people have prepaid.
So let's just look at the
historical record for example. Um,
here, if you can see this, uh, uh, this,
this is blown up as big as it goes,
okay?
Okay?
So this is what you might see as
the historical record of percentage
prepayments,
um,
annualized from 86 to 99.
Say,
okay?
So you noticed that they are very low
here and then they get to be very high and
then they get low again and
then they get high again.
So why do you think that happened?
So what is this?
This is prepayments for
particular mortgage,
8% you take all the people in the country
who started in 1986 with 8% mortgages.
There's a huge crowd of those,
cause that was about what the
mortgage rate was that year.
So a huge collection of people got these
mortgages in 86 and you keep track of
what percentage of them prepaid
really every month. But you're right,
the annualized rate and
then this is the record.
So why do you think it changed
so dramatically like that?
What's the explanation?
What, okay, looks like the stock market,
but I assure you the stock market
had almost nothing to do with it.
Why would prepayments be so low and
then be so high then below than be high?
What do you think was happening?
Interest rate. We just did that.
We just solved out. That was the
whole point of what we were doing.
So you tell me,
what do you think happened in 93?
This is September [inaudible] 93.
I don't know if you can read that.
What do you think was going on then?
Okay,
interest rates got low.
Exactly.
So you may not remember this
because you were barely born in, uh,
in the early nineties there was a
recession and then the government cut the
interest rates. Uh, in the 90s, the early
nineties, there was a recession. And the,
and the government kept cutting interest
rates further and further and further,
it was this huge decline in interest
rates through the early nineties.
And so what happened?
All these people who,
who in in 86 who had these 8% mortgages,
the new interest rates were lower.
And so they all prepaid,
you've got the shocking amount of
prepayment. Okay. So this graph,
which seems sort of, you know, surprising,
and it looks like the stock market
turns out to have nothing to do with the
stock market. It has to do with
where the interest rates are.
Well, do you think interest
rates explain everything? Um,
no. What else could you notice
about the, uh, um, escape?
Okay. What else could you notice?
What else do you think that, uh,
what else have we learned here
by doing these calculations?
Okay.
Well,
what we've learned so far
is that if the people are,
you know, if, if the interest
rates and the economy or at 6%,
that's where they started.
I remember we said they started at
6% or 16% volatility, which is, Oh,
here I had 20% volatility.
Okay. It doesn't matter. I mean,
that's a plausible amount of volatility.
Little High, but okay. That volatility,
the um,
mortgage rate of 8% is not going to give
a value of 100 it's going to cheat the
bank. If the homeowners are acting
rationally, the bank, you know,
the bank could get 120 if the
people weren't acting rationally,
they were just never caught,
never exercising their option.
If they're exercising their option
optimally, the thing was only worth 8%.
Now I told you at that time the interest
rates should have been around seven and
a half percent, not 8%. Given these
a 6% interest rate in the economy,
the mortgage rate should be
seven and a half percent.
So we deduced last time that obviously
not everybody's acting optimally. Well,
you can tell that looking
at this, uh, diagram,
how do you know that not
everybody's acting APP optimally?
Remember these are 86 mortgages,
so it's everybody's taking
them out at the same time,
within a few months of each other,
the same 8% mortgage.
How can you tell from this graph that
they're not exercising their their option
optimally? Completely obvious. Why?
Just looking at it for one
second. You can say, oh,
these people can't be exercising their
option optimally. Why is that? Yes,
they should be exercising all at the same.
Bye.
Okay, so as he says, we've just done the
calculation with those ones and Zeros.
I told you when the right time to exercise
the option is so everybody's got the
same circumstance.
Every single person,
if all they're trying to do is minimize
the present value of their payments,
they should all be
prepaying at the same time.
Here you see that very few people are
prepaying but you know it's getting up to
almost 10% so these people are,
so probably this is a
stupid time to prepay,
but the point is there are still 10%
of them are prepaying and over here,
one presumably you ought to
prepay in the entire year, right?
They have 12 chances during the year.
It takes them an entire year and only
60% of them have have figured out that
they should prepay.
Okay,
so you know they're not acting optimally
so that just from that graph that would
tell you and you have
further evidence of that,
that's evidence that they aren't
acting optimally. Furthermore,
you have evidence that the banks don't
expect them to be act acting optimally
because the banks aren't charging
them eight or 9% interest,
which is what they would need to pay to
get the thing worth a hundred they're
charging them seven and
a half percent interest,
which for the optimal prepare is worth
much less than a hundred to the bank.
So the banks wouldn't do that.
They would just go out of business if
they did something stupid like that,
they wouldn't do that unless they thought
that the homeowners weren't acting,
at least not all of them acting optimally.
Okay,
so suppose you had to predict how people
are going to act in the future and you
want it to trade on that.
How, what would you do?
Okay.
How would you think about predicting it?
So this is the data that you have.
What would you go, what would you do?
You have this data, these are 8% things.
You also have 9% mortgages issued the
year before and then maybe a year before
that there were eight and a half percent
interest and you have that history and
you've got all these different pools
and all these different histories.
How would you think about
figuring out, uh, a prepayment?
How would you predict prepayments?
Well,
the way economists,
macro economists,
at least in the old days used to
make predictions. They would say,
hmm, the first quarter looks pretty
good. Now what are they predicting now?
Now they're saying unemployment is
probably going to keep rising for the next
quarter or two, uh, till
well until the next year.
But at that point,
things are going to turn around and
we expect the economy to get stronger,
come out of its recession and unemployment
should gradually improve from its
high,
which we expect will be 10 and a half
percent to something back down to 6% by
the end of 2011. That's more or
less the economist prediction. Now,
can you make a prediction
like that about prepayments?
Would it make sense to make
a prediction about that?
Why is that an utterly
stupid kind of prediction?
What is the essence of good prediction?
If you wanted to predict something and
you are going to lose a lot of money if
your prediction was wrong,
how would you refine your prediction
compared to what I just gave as a sample
prediction.
Yup.
You have a number of
scenarios and what exactly.
So what he said is if you're even
the slightest bit sophisticated,
you're not going to make a bald,
you know,
noncontingent prediction.
You know,
things are going to get
worse the next two quarters,
then they're going to start getting
better. Then they're going to, you know,
you know t you know things are going
to get as well as they're going to get
after two years.
You'll solve the problem after two years.
You know what happens if another war
breaks out in Iraq? What if Iran, Brahms,
Israel. What if, uh, uh, you know, there's
another crash and commercial real estate.
You know, how could that prediction
possibly turn out to be true?
It's a sure thing. It's going to
be wrong. It's just impossible.
That's going to be right because the
guy making the prediction has made no
contingencies built in his prediction.
You know that guy's making a
prediction for free minimum.
Someone's maybe paying him to hear him,
but he's not going to be panelized.
There was prediction is wrong.
No one in their right mind
would make such a prediction.
So the first thing you should do in
predicting prepayments is to realize that
you've got a tree of possible futures.
And given this tree of possible futures,
you're going to predict different
prepayments depending on what,
where are you going on the tree?
Okay,
so you see prediction is not a simple one,
one event,
it's not a a one shot thing
just as he so aptly put it.
It's a many scenario thing. You have
to predict over many, many scenarios.
What do you think will happen? And
that makes your prediction much better.
Because of course if there is a war in
Iraq and if there is a catastrophe and
Afghanistan and if Iran does bomb
Israel and if the commercial real estate
market collapses,
things are going to be a lot worse than
this original guys prediction. Okay,
so why not?
I mean everybody knows that.
So why not make the prediction
more sensible? Okay, so the art,
so on Wall Street, that's what
everybody's done for 20 years now.
They haven't done it for 30 years.
It's just 20 years that
they've been doing that. Okay.
So when I got to kidder Peabody in 1990
they were making these ones scenario
predictions. So we had to change. And
so I, I, you know, I, it's a long story,
which I'll tell maybe Sunday night
I ended up in charge of the research
department. And so we made, you know,
other firms were doing this already.
We made scenario predictions.
Okay,
so now what kind of scenario predictions
are you going to make when you make
contingent predictions
through an awful lot of them,
you can't even write them all down.
So what you have to do is
you have to have a model.
So what kind of model should
you, uh, should you have? Okay,
well I'll,
I'll tell you now what the standard guys
were doing on Wall Street at the time.
They were saying,
here's interest rate.
Sorry. Here's the present value of a
mortgage is the present value of a call.
We'll mortgage present value of $1 to
principals. So realistic p payments.
So if we go over here,
we'll see that people said,
look, from this graph, it's clear.
They would say that when interest
rates went down, people prepay more.
So why don't we have a function that,
uh, looks like this? Let's say the prep.
So prepay,
that's the percentage,
percentage of remaining
balance that is paid.
Paid off. Okay, so,
so what does that mean? Remember
after you've made your coupon payment,
you have a remaining
balance. You know, B five,
you could pay all of it or none of
it, or half of it. So the, the prepay,
the prepay is what percentage of the
B five. That's just after you've paid,
right? So B two let's do that one B two
just after you've paid 8.88 the remaining
balances now been reduced to be too.
You could in addition to the 8.88 pay
off all of that be to typically some
people who are alert and think it's a
good time to prepay will pay all of me to
others will pay none of B two so if you
aggregate over the whole collection of
people, the prepaid percentage is a
lot of the sums of all their be twos.
What percentage of them are going to
pay off s so we look at the aggregate
prepayment,
that's the old fashioned way.
And we say what percentage of
the remaining balances paid off?
And typically what? So that you'd
make a function like this. You'd say,
well prepay might equal 10% why am I
picking 10% so if you go back to this
picture,
you see that prepayments were
prepayments, you know, seem to be around
10% when nothing's happening. Okay,
so you say 10% plus maybe you're
going to get some more prepayments.
Okay. So you might write, well I just
wrote down a function plus the men,
the men say of point 60 because it never
seems to get over 60% if you look at
that because he never gets over
60% really? So the men of 60
and 15 times
15 times the Max of zero and m
minus our of s minus sigma over one,
three, three. Yeah. That would
be a kind of prepayment function.
What does this say? It says
you pay, it says, okay,
what happens you're normally going to pay.
So this is this whole function here.
So I should write, this is 0.1 plus if
you can read, can you see that over there?
Maybe not. So, um, this plus 0.1, okay,
so there's a baseline of 10% and
if the interest rate is high,
so the interest rate is
above the mortgage rate.
No one else is going to prepaid because
this is going to be a negative number
and this will be zero. So you're
just going to do, um, 0.1%.
Okay.
On the other hand is the interest rate
gets low and falls far enough below the
mortgage rate. People are going
to say to themselves, a Ha,
I have a big incentive to prepay now
maybe think interest rates have gone down
so far, I can no longer hope they're going
to go back up above the mortgage rate.
I should stop.
I should start prepaying more.
So more people are going to prepay and
this thing is going to go up, you know,
and I've just multiply it by
some constant. Okay. And uh,
but it will never go up more than 60%
that's what this function says. And sigma,
this is the volatility AACM all right,
so let's just leave that aside.
So there is a prepayment function that
seems to sort of capture what's going on.
It's usually around 10%
when there's no incentive,
it never gets above 60% but as the
incentive to prepay is interest rates get
lower and the incentive to repaying
pieces more and more people prepay.
That's kind of the idea.
All right.
And then you would fit
fancier curves than that.
You would look at an minus. Rt and
you would fit a curve, you know,
that looks like this. So if there's just
a little bit of incentive to prepay,
the rates were a little bit
lower than the mortgage rate.
Nobody does it then quickly,
a lot of people do it and
then they stopped doing it.
So this is like 60% and you know,
most of the time you around 10% and uh,
you know,
you're trying to fit this curve.
You'd have millions of parameters
and since you have so much data,
you could fit parameters. Okay,
that was the old fashioned way.
And that's how people would
predict, uh, prepayments.
Now that's not going to turn
out to be such a great way,
but it's certainly teaches you something.
So let's look at what happens if you
now with those realistic prepayments,
you compute the value of a mortgage.
So the,
this is the prepayment that you'd
get for the different rates.
And so you can see that
as the rates go down, um,
as the rates go down, the total
prepayment is going up. And by the way,
it's more than 60% because you've got
this 10% added to the 60% so the most,
it could be a 70% which it hits over here.
So you get 70% is the maximum prepayments.
And you know as interest rates get higher
it no one prepays except the 10% of
guys. Now, by the way, why are
people prepaying over here?
Even when the rates are so high,
it's because some people are moving or
they're getting divorced and they have to
sell their house.
So obviously you're going to get some
prepayments no matter what people have to
prepay.
And why is it that people never prepay
more than 60% historically or 70% because
not everybody pays attention.
Now I called them the dumb guys last time,
but as I said, you know, I
probably fit into that category.
It's people who are distracted
and doing other things,
so just not paying attention. And
so they don't realize, you know,
they'll know what's going on if they
don't realize they should be prepaying.
So as interest rates go down,
more people prepay interest rate goes up,
less people prepay.
And if you did some historical thing
and you don't figure it out the right
parameters, you'd get a
prepayment function. So you know,
how did I figure out this was 15,
how do I figure out this was 0.6 why
should I divide this by one 33 what?
Sigma. Okay. Once you
get those parameters,
historically you now have
a weld determined, uh,
behavior rule,
what people are going to prepay.
And from that you can figure out what the
prices are of any mortgage by backward
induction. So how would you do
it again, by backward induction?
The same way we always did it over here.
Okay. What, what, what would you do over
here? How would you change this rule?
Well, you would just be feeding in
the prepayment function. Okay, so,
so what would the prepayment function be?
Well,
people wouldn't be doing a minimum here,
right?
They're not deciding whether or not to
prepay their just prepaying. So this is,
Oh, let's get rid of that. There
are prepaying. So some of them are,
so this is the value of a
dollars left of principle.
So some of them are prepaying
and that's the function.
So prepay and that depends
on what node you're at.
And here it says what fraction,
what percentage of the remaining
balances being prepaid.
So that tells you that rule,
who's prepaying and then with the rest
of the money that's going on until next
time,
one minus that same thing,
one minus prepay times
exactly what we had before.
Okay. So this part of the
dollar got prepaid immediately.
So that's the cash that
went to the mortgage holder.
The rest of the cash got save till next
time. And here's what happens to it.
Okay, you have to make your coupon,
then you have a remaining balance.
And then whatever's gonna
happen is gonna happen.
Okay? So that's the uh,
okay. So doing that by,
so you'll study this and you'll figure
out, I'm sure it will, you know,
it takes a little bit of
effort to see that through.
But with half an hour staring at it,
you're all understand how this works
and you'll read it in a spreadsheet.
So you can figure out the value of every
of a mortgage. Okay? So that's, that's,
uh, you know, you'd a
value of a mortgage. Okay.
And now we could start doing experiments
by changing the parameters and see how
the mortgage works. Now, before
I do that, I want to say that,
that there's a better way
to do this. Okay? I mean,
maybe these numbers are estimated
were interest rates didn't.
What's a better way of doing it? So how,
how would I, how did I do it at Ellington?
How did we, I mean, at kidder Peabody,
how did we predict prepayments?
What's another way of looking at,
at the prepayments and why you could,
so let me, let me, let me tell you
something that's missing. Suppose that,
um, I used to ask people
who wanted to work at,
at a kidder Peabody or Ellington,
the following little simple puzzle.
And most of the genius mathematicians
always got this answer wrong. Um,
of course we hired them anyway,
but they'd always get this wrong.
So the question is, suppose you've
got a group of people like this,
okay?
And you figure out what the value of the
mortgages and interest rates have been
constant all of his time. Let's suppose
for one month, interest rates shoot up,
shoot down, interest rates
collapsed and half the pool,
60% of the pool disappears. So now
you've only got 40% of the people left.
You have before.
And then interest rates return to exactly
where they were to begin with. Okay.
Should the pool that's left be worth 40%
of the pool that you had just here or
more than 40% or less than 40% so
remember you had a hundred people here.
You're the bank who's lent them the money.
You know your value in the
mortgage payments they're
going gonna make to you and
you're getting a certain
amount of money from them.
60% of them suddenly disappeared
in one month leaving 40 left.
But now interest rates are back
exactly where they were before.
Is the value of the mortgage starting
here with the 40% pool worth 40% of what
it was originally more than 40% or
less than 40% what do you think?
Yes.
More than 40%
exactly.
So that's an incredibly important point.
It's called the opposite
of adverse selection.
Every one of these events is
selecting the people left,
not adversely. What's the, not perversely,
what's the opposite of
adverse favorably to you.
So the guys who are left are all losers,
but that's what you want to deal with.
You don't want to trade with the geniuses.
You want to trade with the guy.
He's not paying any attention.
So the guys left are the people who are
never going to prepay or hardly ever
going to prepay. And so
it's much better. Now,
this function doesn't capture that at all,
right?
It doesn't say anything.
It just says you're a prepayments
depending on where you are.
So you know whether you were here or here,
uh,
you're going to get the same prepayment.
But we know that that's not
going to be the case. In fact,
it's clear that over here there must
have been a much bigger incentive than
there was over there.
So the prepayments are the same.
But actually interest rates here, we're
vastly lower than interest rates there.
Okay. So, so this is not
such a good function.
So how would you improve?
What would you do to take into account
this adverse selection and actually pro
verse selection,
what is the opposite of adverse?
Okay, well I'll do that. Okay. So how
would you, what would you think to do?
You know, your whole livelihood depends
on it. You know, there are millions,
trillions of dollars at stake here.
You've got a model prepayments correctly.
So how would you think of doing this?
Just giving you some sense of what a
hedge fund does or what anyone on in this
market would have to do. Well, most
of them did this. Of course they got,
okay,
so what would you do?
Yup,
I old Morgan because the market is
probably over underestimating their map.
What you would buy it up
when? Right after, right here.
You'd buy it up right there.
Okay,
but what model would you
use to predict prepayments?
Not this one. What? So what would,
what would you do to do well?
How would you imagine doing it?
You'd imagine making a model just like
your intuition. So what does that mean?
Doing
that? One's asking you to
run a research department,
make a model of forecasting prepayments.
All the data you have is
aggregate data like that.
You can't observe individual homeowners
and those days they wouldn't give you
the information.
I'll explain all that Sunday night.
So this is the kind of data you have.
You know what the average,
what the whole group of
people is doing every year,
but what would you do to build the model?
Yeah,
adverse selection is very important. Or
Pro verse election. I, I'm really free.
It's embarrassing. I don't remember
the word. Favorable selection.
Very important thing. So how would
you capture that in your model?
Yup.
Okay,
so maybe another thing you could
do and that it's going to start,
what if you,
instead of having having this function
that says what the aggregate is going to
do, all the data's aggregates, all you
can do is test against aggregate data.
But suppose you were you, you,
you said, okay, the world,
all we can see is the aggregate,
but the people really acting or
individuals acting, not the aggregate.
It's the sum of individual activities.
So what we should do now is have
different kinds of people. Okay. So,
oh Gosh, sorry. It wasn't,
they are already, um,
so let's go back to where we
were before. Okay. So realistic.
MMM.
Okay. What you ought to do
is you ought to say, well 8%.
Okay. Remember we had two kinds of people.
You've already got two kinds of people.
Sorry.
We've got these guys,
the guys who never call. So there are
people you know, that's a kind of person.
And suppose you go down here and you have
the people who are optimally prepaying.
Suppose you imagine that half the people
were optimally prepaying and half the
people never prepaid.
Well,
would that explain this
favorable selection? Absolutely.
It would explain it because when
you went through your little tree,
anyone here and here and here and here,
by the time you got down here,
all those people, all the,
all the optimal prepares,
they're all prepaying.
So you start off with half
optimal guys and half asleep guys,
once you get down here,
all the optimal guys have disappeared.
And the pool of what's left is all asleep.
So of course the pool is worth
lunch more here, you know,
then given the interest rates
and it was over here. In fact,
if it goes back then again to hear,
you know where it was before. Sorry,
that's same line. If it goes back to here,
if I had done this right and all I've
got to go back twice here and then here.
So once it goes back to here, if
it goes here, here, here and here,
okay, then the pool is going to be much
more valuable here than it started there.
They're half as many people,
but it's worth much more than
half of what it was there. Okay.
So the way to do this is to break.
So then you're looking at the individuals,
you're saying one class
of people's very smart,
the other class of people or one
class of people's very alert,
a much better word,
one class of people's very alert,
one class of people's very unlearned.
And as you go through the tree,
the alert people are going to disappear
faster than the non alert people.
And that's why you're going to have a
favorable selection of people who's left
in the pool. Okay. Well,
of course there's no extremes of
perfectly rational or perfectly,
uh, you know, asleep in the economy.
So what you can do is you can make people
in between, you can have people who,
how do you make them in between?
Well, suppose that, for example,
I only did one thing.
Suppose it's costly to prepay.
Some people just say to themselves,
you know,
I'm gonna have to take a whole day off
of work. I'm not going to write my paper.
I might lose some business that
I was going to do that day.
Whole Bunch of stuff I'm losing.
So unless I think you know,
I'm going to subtract that, the,
you know, I'm not going to prepay,
not gonna even think about doing it unless
I can get at least a certain benefit
from having done it.
Okay.
So you can add a cost of prepaying and
people aren't going to prepay unless the
gain that they have by prepaying exceeds
the cost of doing the prepayment.
So to take the simplest case,
let's suppose very active,
nevermind the thinking and all that.
The very act of prepaying going to
the bank literally costs you money.
So if you have,
you know,
a value of if the thing is a
hundred and you can prepay,
know if you do your calculations and don't
prepay today it's worth 98 and if you
prepaid today the remaining balances 94
you're $4 but if the cost of prepayment
is five you're still not going to do it.
So you get a guy with a high cost of
prepaying and infinite cost of prepaying,
he's going to look like
he's totally an alert.
A guy with zero cost of paying is going
to look like he's totally alert. Okay?
So you can have gradations of a,
of,
of a rationality and you can
have different dimensions.
So you can have costs of prepaying
and you can have alertness.
What's the percentage of time you're
actually paying attention that month?
What fraction of the month do
you actually pay attention?
And you can have a distribution of people,
different costs and different alert,
nces.
Okay.
So that's the model that I built
that's a simplified for our book.
Gives you an idea. Okay. So, um,
here's this burnout effect that I showed
that if you take the same coupons but
an older one rather than a, uh,
an older one that's burned out,
we'll always prepay slower.
So the pink one is always less than
the blue one because it went through an
opportunity to prepay.
Okay.
So here you start with a pool
of guys on the right, okay.
On the right. And then after a
while, after time has gone down,
a lot of them have prepaid and you'd get,
so here's alertness and costs, you know,
but after time,
so you describe a person by what is cost
of free paying is and how alert he is.
The more alert he is and the
lower the cost of prepaying,
the closer to rational is,
the less alert is the higher the cost of
repaying the closer to the totally dumb
guy he is. And so you
can have a, you know,
a whole normally distributed distribution
of people and over time those groups
are going to uh,
be reduced because a lot of them are
prepaying but they won't be reduced
symmetrically.
The low cost,
high alertness guys are going to disappear
a much faster and the pool's going to
get more and more favorable
to you. Okay. And so anyway,
all you have to do is parameterize
the, the cost. You know,
what the distribution of
people in the population,
what the standard deviation
and a expectation of cost
is and of alertness is.
And that tells you what this
distribution looks like.
So you're fitting for numbers and you've
got thousands of pools and hundreds and
hundreds of months and
fitting for parameters.
You can end up fitting all the data.
So look at what happens here.
So here's the same data. So
I just tell you, you know,
I know that in the population,
given what I've calculated
in the 90s there,
I know what fraction of the people
have this cost and that alertness,
what fraction of the people
are so close to, you know,
dumb that their costs are astronomical
and the alertness is tiny. What,
what fraction of the people have almost
no cost and in a very high alertness,
you know, so I'm only estimating
four parameters cause I'm
assuming it's normally
distributed giving that fixed pool.
I have people,
I applied that to the beginning of every
single mortgage and I just crank out
what would those guys do,
you know,
in the tree if they knew
what the volatilities were,
when would they decide to prepay?
And then I have to follow a scenario
out in the future. And I say,
well along this path,
which guy would prepay in which guy
wouldn't prepay and what would the total
prepayments look along that path?
And so this has generated the pink line
from the model with no knowledge of the
world except they fit those parameters.
And look how close it is
to what actually happened.
So it turns out that it was incredibly
easy to predict a contingently predict
what prepayments we're going to be and
therefore to be able to value mortgages.
Okay. And this was a secret
that not many people, you know,
a bunch of people understood,
but not that many. Understood.
And so for years we were
trading at our hedge fund,
the first a kid her then at
Ellington with this ability to,
to contingently forecast
prepayments at a very high rate.
And why was it so stable?
The prediction and so reliable,
it's because the class of people
stay pretty much the same.
And every year they'd be the same
kinds of people with the same kinds of
behaviors. Some were very
alert, some are very, not alert,
but the distribution of types
was more or less the same.
And you could predict with pretty good
accuracy what was going to happen from
year to year.
Of course,
then in after 2003 or so,
the class of people started to radically
change and many more people who never
got mortgages before it got them.
And it became much harder to
predict what they were going to do.
But so in the old days it
was pretty easy to predict.
And why was it so easy to predict?
Because it was an agent based model.
Okay,
okay. Agent base. So by the way,
I added this volatility here.
So these guys who just ran regressions,
they had to have a volatility
or something, parameters.
So you see as volatility goes up,
the prepayments are slower. Well,
they just had to notice that and
build it right into their function.
I didn't even have to
think of that or burnout.
None of those things did
I have to think about.
Because if you're a guy optimizing
here and volatility goes up,
so you reset the tree so that the
interest rates can change faster,
the option is worth more.
So you're going to wait longer.
You're not going to just exercise it
right away because you've got a chance,
you know the prices will really go up.
So you can wait a little
longer for it to wait longer.
So prepayments will slow down.
Okay.
So all I'm saying all this is just
to say that if you have the right,
so it's agent based,
it's a contingent predictions,
contingent predictions
in those two things together enable you
to make quite reliable predictions about
the future if you're in a
stable environment and a,
so what seems like a bewildering amount
of stuff turns out to be pretty easy to
explain. Okay. So now what happens?
Okay.
Yeah. So do you have any
questions here or should I
yes.
Some sort of what I had to figure out
what the mean. And the variance is.
So how do I know?
So there there's mean and variance of
costs and mean and variance of alertness
to get that distribution right.
So how do I know what the population,
so let me just put the picture up again.
Um,
okay. Here. So given, so who
are the hyper rational guys?
They're the people with the really high
alertness up there and the really low
cost. Although the guys
back there, there, the uh,
okay, they're the hyper.
Um, or maybe it was the guy.
He's not one of these corners with
very high alertness and very low cost.
I forgot which way the scale works.
Um, it might be going down. So anyway,
the guys with very high alertness and
very low cost or the hyper rational people
at the other corner,
you've got the guys who have very
low alertness and very high cost.
They're the people who you're going to
make a lot of money on if you're the bank.
So how do I know how many people
are of each type? Well, I don't,
I have to, I have to, you know,
fit this distribution. But you see,
I have so much data,
I've got this kind of curve,
this kind of curve I've got for
every starting year, you know,
for the whole history.
And there are so many different interest
rates and so many different. So,
you know,
I'm applying that same population at
the beginning of every single curve and
then seeing what happens to my
prediction versus what really happened.
And so I can always,
so I've got thousands and thousands and
thousands of data points and only four
parameters to fit.
So I picked the four parameters to
fit the data as much as possible.
If I assumed everybody was perfectly
alert enough instead of that curve that I
showed you, I put a huge crowd
here of perfectly rational people,
then I would have found that I
would've gotten prepayments, you know,
at 100% up there and at
zero all the way over here.
And so it wouldn't have fit that curve.
So that's how I knew that there couldn't
be that many perfectly rational people.
Okay.
Yes.
You mean how do I know cost and alertness?
Maybe there's some other factors. Yes.
Well, okay, there probably are
other factors. So I, so what,
what would you common sense
of we think are the factors?
What keeps people from prepaying?
I think the most obvious one is just
a huge hassle and they're not paying
attention.
So those are the first two I thought him,
could you think of another one? Maybe
they arrange their age. Okay. Exactly.
So maybe, so maybe demography
has an effect on it. Okay.
So maybe for example, you get more
sophisticated the older you get, so okay.
That was another factor we put in.
So I'm not telling you all the factors,
but these were the two main, these
were the two main factors. Okay?
Another factor was growing sophistication.
We call it the smart factor.
Okay? So that's another
factor. Okay. But, but uh,
so over time you'd get
more sophisticated. So, um,
okay, so anyway, the point is
with a few of these factors,
you see you got a pretty good fit and
it was pretty reliable and you could
predict what gonna happen.
Contingently eh? Okay? And so now what,
so now if you want to
trade mortgages, how, what,
what are some of the interesting
things that happen? Okay? Well,
okay.
Okay. The first interesting
thing to notice is that, um,
what do you think happens as the
interest rate goes down? Okay?
So the first thing to notice is,
all right,
so I'll just make to, uh,
ask you two questions.
Let's go on the other side
of running out of room.
Suppose that you have the mortgage value.
You know what you get in the tree bite.
So in this tree that we've built,
you know, here's the tree.
It's going like that.
And at every node we're predicting,
you know,
for each class of people were
predicting where his ones are.
So that class is prepaying.
The other class is not as
smart. So they've, you know,
they're not prepaying here,
but maybe when things get really low
they'll start prepaying here. So each,
each class of people, each cost alertness
type has its own tree, the same tree,
but its own behavior on the tree. Then
I add them all together. Okay. So,
um,
what happens with the
starting interest rate?
Okay,
so here we had 0.06 and this value was,
you know,
98 or something.
Right now suppose the interest
rate went down to 0.05,
I drew this picture of interest
and mortgage value.
Okay.
What do you think happens? So the
interest starts, this is, you know,
98 6% is there is the
interest rate goes down.
What do you think happens to
the value of the mortgage?
If you're a bank and you've fixed the,
the mortgage rate is 8% hey
that's a fixed mortgage rate,
but now you've moved in
the tree from here to here.
Do you think your mortgage is going
to go up in value or down in value?
It's going to go up because the interest
rates are lower and the present value
of the payments is getting higher.
Okay. So if the interest rate goes down,
the mortgage is going to go
up like that typically. Okay.
But will it keep going
up like this and this,
if it were a bond it would go
up like that. Right? A bond,
you know a one year bond which owed one
over one plus r you know we keep going
up and up the value far got negative
say it would go up but you know,
so as our got negative and
would go way up like that.
So does the mortgage keep going up like
that? As the interest rate goes down,
is the value of the mortgage is going
to get higher and higher and higher?
Huh?
Suppose the guys optimal, what's going
to happen? This is a hundred here.
What will happen?
Yup.
He's going to eventually figure out
that he should prepay like you know,
so it'll go like this.
If he's perfectly optimal,
he'll never let it go above a hundred so
it's going to go something like this is
the interest rate gets higher,
you get crushed.
And as the interest rate gets lower,
you don't get the full upside
because he's prepaying, you know,
at a hundred he's never
letting it go above 100
okay.
Right? So if he's not so
optimal, maybe you'll value
will go up, but not, you know,
not so astronomically high.
So this idea that the mortgage curve
instead of being like this goes like that.
This is what was called
negative convexity.
Okay.
Now the next thing,
the next thing to know is suppose that,
um, suppose that the thing is
the guys are partly irrational.
So it's going above a hundred. Okay.
So it's starting to go like this.
Then what do you think is the
interest rate gets really low?
What's going to happen?
All right. You just said it.
So if the guy was rational,
perfectly rational would go like that.
He'd never let it go above a hundred
but now suppose guys are not totally
rational.
What's going to happen is they're going
to sort of as rates get a little bit low,
they're not, they're going to overlook
the fact that they should prepay.
So now it's advantageous to you.
Things are worth more than a hundred
but if rates get incredibly low,
even the dumbest guy,
the least, the least,
the highest cost guy is going to
realize he is an advantage to prepay.
And so things are going
to go back down like that.
So the value is going
to be quite complicated.
So this is the mortgage value
as a function of interest rates.
Just common sense will tell you
this, that okay, in a typical bond,
as the interest rate gets lower,
the present value gets higher.
You should expect a curve like that.
But because of the option,
if we're rationally and to exercise,
the curve would never get above a
hundred it would have to go like that.
But now if people are irrational,
you can take advantage of them.
And get more than a hundred out of them.
But if the situation
gets so favorable to you,
it becomes blindingly obvious
eventually to them that uh, you know,
they're getting screwed and eventually
they act and bring it all the way back to
a hundred again. So this value
of the mortgage looks like that.
So that's a very tricky thing
I'll even write. Very tricky.
Okay.
So if you don't know what you're doing,
you could easily get yourself
a hurt holding mortgages, okay?
You could suddenly find yourself
losing money holding mortgages.
So that's my next subject here.
I want to talk about hedging.
Okay? So we know something
now about valuing mortgages.
I want to talk about hedging and what
hedge funds do and what everyone on Wall
Street should be doing.
Okay? Which is hedging and I'm to,
I'm going to, okay. So
if you hold a mortgage,
you're going to hold that because maybe
you can lend a hundred to a bunch of
people, but actually get a value
that's more than a hundred.
So it looks like you're here,
but you know, if interest
rates change a little bit,
suddenly this huge value,
you thought you had Mike collapse back
down to 100 or the interest rates might
go up and am I collapsed to way
below a hundred. So, you know,
you look like you're well off,
but there are scenarios where you could
lose money and you want to protect
yourself against that. So how do you go
about doing it? What does hedging mean?
And I want to put it in the context,
the old context of the world series.
Okay.
Which we started with before.
So it's easier to understand there.
And I,
and so many of you will have
thought about this before,
so you'll be able to answer it,
but if I put it in the mortgage context,
it would seem just too difficult. I don't
know why I did that. So a world series,
I'm going to lower it in a second.
So suppose that the
Yankees have a 60% chance.
I said beating the Dodgers, I thought
the Dodgers would be in the world series,
60% chance of winning any gain.
Uh,
against the Phillies and the world series.
And you are a bookie and your fellow
bookies all understand that it's 60%.
So some naive Philly fan
comes to you and says,
I want to bet $100 that the
Phillies win the world series. Okay,
should you take the better not
yes,
you should take the bat because 60% of
the time you're going to win $100 though.
No, you, yes, you should take the bad.
If he bet on one game, you would, uh,
make with 60% probability you'd win a
hundred and was 40% probability you'd lose
a hundred.
So that means on average,
you're expectation is equal to 20.
So if he's willing to bet $100 on
the Phillies winning the world,
that winning the first game
of the series with you,
you know that you're expected
chance of winning is $20.
You're expecting to win $20 from the guy.
Now suppose he's willing to make the
same bet $100 for the entire series.
Okay.
What's your chance of winning
and what's your expected profit from him?
Is it less than 2020 or more than 20
more than 20. Okay. It's going to turn
out to be, so a seven game series,
I'm going to turn out to be 42 which we're
going to figure out in a second. Okay.
But what's your risk? What's
your risk? If it's one game,
in either case, you might lose $100. The
Phillies, you know, they're, they're,
you know,
they're probably going to lose,
but there's a chance something
goes crazy and we'll, you know,
some unknown guy hits five home runs
in the first four games or something in
some other unknown guy hits another
four home runs and you know,
you'll lose the world series.
You could lose $100 and maybe the guy's
not getting $100 per $100,000 or $100
million. You know, you've
got a favorable bet,
but you don't want to run the risk of
losing even though there's not that high a
chance you're going to lose. What
can you do about it? Okay. So,
uh,
well you know that there's these other
bookies out there who every game are
willing to bet at odd 60 40 either
direction on the Phillies are the Yankees
because they just all know
they're just like you.
You all know that the odds are 60%
for the Yankees winning every game.
So suppose this naive guy,
the Phillies fan comes up Hugh and
bet $100 on the world series that the
Phillies or when
you don't want to run
the risk of losing $100,
you know there are these other
bookies were willing to take bets,
a game at a time, 60 40 odds.
What should you be doing?
What would you do?
Okay,
yes.
so what would you do?
So this guy has come to you and you're
not going to be able to give the,
we're going to find out exactly
what you should do in one second,
but let's just see how far you can
get by reason, without calculation,
what you saw. Okay, this guy
has come to you and said,
I'm betting $100 on the Phillies
winning the world series.
This is the night before the first game.
Every book he's standing by ready
to take bets at 30 to 20 odds.
What would you uh,
do?
Yeah,
that what? Yeah, how much?
you bet the whole hundred dollars.
Well,
but would you bet the whole
hundred dollars in the first game?
The guy's only bet $100
on the whole series.
Okay.
Okay. So it's not so
obvious what to do. Right?
But he's got exactly the right idea.
You can hedge your bet by betting on the,
uh,
okay. You can hedge your bet. Okay, so
here we are. Shouldn't have put that down.
Oh, I don't, don't tell me I turned
it off. That would just kill me.
Tell meant to hit mute.
I think I hit off.
Okay.
Okay. So, oh, how dumb.
Okay,
so you would bet on the,
well,
while that warms up,
I can see it. Um, all right.
So what happens is you'll have a tree
which looks like this and like this,
like this and like this.
Okay. Like this and like this.
And let's say we go out
a few games like this.
Now this is a one, two, three game series.
All right? So I've done it. Here's the,
here's the, uh, here's the
start of the world series.
This is the world series spreadsheet
you had before. Now here's the start.
Here's game,
okay?
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
So if you win the one, if the Yankees
win the series, they get $100.
Okay?
Okay? You get $100. Sorry.
Oh, what an idiot. Um, one one. Oh,
oh,
okay. So every time you end up above
the star, when more than you lose,
you get $100. On the other hand,
if you lose more than you win,
you lose $100.
Okay?
Okay.
And so control copy here is losing,
okay?
$100. Okay? So now this tree, you
remember from doing it before,
it's just by backward induction.
If you look at the thing up there,
it says you get, you know, 60%,
I think was the number we
figured out a over here. So,
right? So 60% is the vow probability
of the Yankees win any game.
And so if you figure it, so, um,
you take any node like
a, you know, this one,
you're always taking 60% of
the value at the up up here,
plus 40% of the value here.
Okay. So if you do that,
you find out that the value to you is $42.
Just what we said.
So let's put that in the
middle of the screen.
Yeah.
And that value is $42. Okay. Now if you,
if the Yankees win the first game,
you're in much better shape.
So winning the first game means
you moved up to this node here,
all of a sudden you went from $42 to $64.
Okay?
Okay.
And if the Yankees lost the first game,
he would have gone down to that value,
which is like $9.
Okay. You're expected winnings when
the Yankees are down a game, you know,
they're still a better team.
So actually it's more likely even after
losing the first game that the anchors
would still win the series.
But you've watched,
so you see the risk that you're running
and you can calculate this. If so,
what should you do in the very first game?
This tells you that you're
expected winnings is 42 of
course 0.6 times 64 that's
38.4 plus 0.4 times nine
is a 3.6 that is $42 okay?
So that's 42 cause it's an average of
this and this and 64 is the average of 0.6
to this. And point for that.
Okay? So what should you do?
Well, on average you're going to make
$42. What's the essence of hedging?
You want to guarantee that you
make $42 no matter what happens,
no matter who wins the series, you want
to end up with 42 extra dollars. Assuming,
you know the interest rate is zero from
the beginning to the end of the series.
So how can you arrange that?
What can you do?
Well, okay, so that's the
mystery. Give you one second
to try and think it through.
Otherwise there'll be no, you should
get this. What would you do here?
Are there no, um, baseball bookies in the
Yup.
Uh,
that, that you view at, you can trust. Um,
and then you trust the rest of it too.
Well, you can bet with another
booking, it's 60 to 40 odds.
If the Yankees win the first game.
You're just doing great fact from
the Yankees lose the first game.
You know, you're looking to
be in a little bit of trouble.
So the point is you're not going
get the payoffs till the very end.
He's a plus a hundred or minus a hundred,
but already by the first game,
you're either doing better than you were
before or worse than you were before.
You're already in effect suffering
some risk at the very beginning.
So this is one of the great
ideas of finance. You can,
you shouldn't hedge the final outcome.
You should hedge next day's outcome.
If you are marking to market, that's
what you'd have to do marking to market.
You'd have to say, my position
now, my bet is worth $64.
The Yankees lost the first game.
The bet would be worth $9.
So what does it mean to protect yourself?
Not just protect yourself against
what's happening? At the end.
That's really what you want to do.
But in order to do that,
you should protect yourself every
day against what could happen.
So every day you should end up with 42
here and 42 there because after all,
that's what you're trying to lock in.
No matter who wins the first game,
you should still say I'm $42 a head
cause I got myself in this position.
So how could you do that?
Well let's bet at three to two odds,
right?
60 40 is three to two odds.
Let's make a bet with another
bookie at 22 and 33 here.
So 20 to put it in the wrong place.
This is the 33 and this is 22 but plus
33 and minus 22 so what are you doing
here?
Notice that this is two times 11 this
is three times 11 this is 60 40 odds.
I'm betting on the Phillies.
If the Phillies win one game,
I collect $33 that's what I
should do. That he said, he said,
go to the bookie across the
street and bet on one game,
not the whole series better in one game
with that book, he across the street,
$33 versus $22.
Okay?
Let's say you can only bet one game at
a time with the other bookies. Actually,
maybe you were saying all along
better on the whole series.
Let's say you can only bet one game
at a time with the other, uh, bookies.
You'd bet $33 on the Phillies and
the first game that night you,
Philly fan is put up $100 on the series.
You're in the first game going to put $33.
You've taken his bed. So you're, you're,
you're hoping the Yankees win.
But that's bad to be in a position when
you have to hope you don't want to do
that. So you take his bet
on the Phillies, you know,
cause he's given you a hundred
to a hundred odds. That's
even odds. Even though,
you know the Yankees have
a 60% chance of winning,
you go to the bookie across
the street and you bet at 60,
40 odds on the Phillies,
but you don't put the whole hundred,
you only bet $33 of it. So if you
win, you get $33. If you lose,
you only have to pay the guy 22.
So what's going to happen
after the first day?
This position is going to be worth 42
and this position is also going to be
worth 42 exactly where you
started. So because, uh,
when in the first game is going to put
you so far ahead in your bet with the
first naive Philly,
better and a loss in the first game
is going to put you so far behind,
you hedge that possibility by going,
um,
33,
22 in favor of the Phillies.
You take a big bet on the Yankees and
then you make a smaller bet on the
Phillies that cancels out part
of the big bet on the Yankees,
but you've made the two at different odds.
And so on net,
you're still going to be
$42 a head, okay? So that's,
let's just pause for a second and see
if you, you got that. So by doing this,
you can't possibly lose any money.
And now you're going to repeat this bet
down here in here. Okay? So in the next,
um, you see where do things go
next here or you're down $8.
Okay? If you, if you lost again,
you'd be down $32 now things would
really be bad after the Yankees lost two
games in a row. Your bet with
the original, your original
bet would look terrible,
okay? But things aren't so bad
because you've been betting,
you bet on the Phillies here,
you already made $33. Okay?
So how much money do you think you'll,
you'll,
you should be betting on
the Phillies down here.
Okay? Well you want to
lock in $42 at every node,
no matter what happens,
this $42 by making the right offsetting
bet you can keep 42 everywhere here
until the very end.
And so no matter what happened,
you can always end up with $42 hey,
that's the essence of hedging. So let's,
let's just say it again.
What the idea is. Okay?
It's a great idea and we don't have
time to go through all the details.
But the great ideas, this, you've
made some gigantic bet with somebody.
Why do you bet with anybody? Because
you think you know more than they do.
The whole essence of trading and finances,
you think you understand the world
better than somebody else. So, so you're,
you know,
understand that means you
think something's going to
turn out one way that the
other guy doesn't really
know is going to happen.
So you're making a bet on whether
you're right or wrong. Okay?
So just because you think you, when you
say you know, you don't know for sure,
you just have a better idea than he does.
So you don't want,
you want to use your idea
without running the risk.
So how can you do it if your
idea is really correct, okay?
There may be a way so that you
can eliminate the luck. So here,
if you really know the odds are 60,
40 year class of bookies
knows the odds are 60, 40,
and some other guys who doesn't
know things, the odds are 50, 50,
and is willing to bet against you.
You can lock in your $42 for sure.
You don't just take a bat and,
uh, you know, hope you win,
you can take a bat and then hedge
it to lock in your profits for sure.
A step by step.
And that's what we have to explain how
that dynamic hedging words. So, um,
I have to stop unfortunately. So
Sunday we're going to do the, uh,
glass about mortgages.